you
welcome to software engineering mix
vol.2 so this is the second instance we
actually at one last year and you
actually not going to see what I'm going
to present so yeah so
it's going to be any second okay so so
welcome to software genomics thank you
so much for coming just to give you some
idea of what we have planned for today
so basically the soft engine makes the
idea is to to connect people to bring
people together to talk about software
engineering and specifically we want to
connect people from academia with
Microsoft engineers because i get for
past few days your faculty summit lots
of fantastic software engineering
researchers came to true theatre to
learn about microsoft and about related
research trends and we want to use this
opportunity to basically have them also
meet our grade soft engineers at
microsoft so essentially to connect
academia with practice and also one of
the courses to make academics aware of
for real problems of today's software
development and also to potentially
brainstorm practical solutions so last
year we had a very generous software
engineering mix with a very wide range
of topics and sincere we are going
actually to be a bit more focused
specifically on open source and also fee
analysis of large k software
repositories so what we have planned for
you is so this is our track listing for
today so you'll be right now in for
welcome tarek we're going to have a free
presentations after this and fees are
basically meant to set the stage for
what's going to come later on during the
day we can't have a speed dating session
so for idea is that you can see some
table some chairs in feedback as we're
going to move to feedback and we're
going to interact with each other in
like very quick five minutes slots where
basically people get to talk to each
other to learn about each other's
interests each other's problems in doing
software development when we gonna have
a quick break presentations we gonna do
a brainstorming in the afternoon after
lunch and was it going to take a group
picture and then we have after the group
brainstorming session we've actually a
showcase of some really creates of open
source projects
which is also going to be in WebEx we
already see some of demonstrations and
that's actually all i had to say so
please enjoy a day talk to each other
talk to people you don't know and run
about today's of engineering problems
and so the first presentation will be
given by trudat bishop who is actually
in charge of the Microsoft Research open
source programs and just to tell you
Microsoft Research open source programs
and she is to tell you lots of great
things about what we do with open source
here right good morning everyone I've
delighted to be the first speaker
largely because I have to fly off to
Russia this morning so I'm really sorry
I'm not going to be here for all the
fantastic tracks that Tom's planned i'll
have to listen to other tracks on the
plane i'm so pleased to be able to talk
to you about this topic of industrial
research for more than a year now I've
been working on what Microsoft Research
is offering in terms of the open-source
pace and in the last few months we've
been trying to put this together with my
intern over here Aaron and we have some
fantastic results which I think will
lead to some discussion so as we know
OSS is too important things that's many
things but it's a development
methodology and when you bring that to
an industrial context that really
disrupts a lot of the way that things
were done in the past so you can read
those big blocks but you can realize
that this is not the way that Windows
was shipped you know with three month or
even more like a year type of planning
so things get done a lot faster users
are involved in what's going on and
there's a very different life style
inside projects which are open source
that's in the product groups and we have
included in our in our results which
I'll show you some product group
projects as well
not just the one from Microsoft Research
very early release hi modularity these
are all things that have to be taken
into account the other thing is which is
particularly important from a industrial
viewpoint is this issue of licensing so
as you know people talk in the outside
about proprietary software and free
software and so on and they generally
mean proprietaries bad free is good and
so this is not always the case then the
lines are never very cleanly drawn we
have here somebody who's just flown in
from Red Hat where he is an intern and I
mean that's of incredibly popular system
but it's neither free but it is
open-source very popular a great great
model from a spawned by IBM now these
are some of the things that one has to
take into account when you're thinking
about licensing and of course as we know
the many licenses are having my
appendices you know all the different
licenses and I don't want to go into
that I just want to sensitize us here
today that this is an issue in
industrial software and if you're an
ordinary researcher saying whoops I'm
going to open source of our software
well without direction or thought you
could land up in the wrong place with
respect to licensing so companies and
universities are suspect as well do
apply their mind to what should be done
in this regard so much more simpler than
that are the three words that I always
think about for open source and that is
that they're you create open source you
use it and you contribute to it and
really if you don't have all of those
three then you don't have the whole
equation
so let's move on this is an example of a
particular open source tool python tools
which is created here in Microsoft and
it's inserted into a non open source to
visual studio which is one of the
biggest money earners for Microsoft
that's a very interesting model it means
that you can have open source software
with its license and all the licenses
that go with it I think there are about
125 of these 150 inside something that
ships for monetary gain and that's also
something one can do these days and we
do it and that makes open sourcing much
more liberal much more attractive in
many many ways now at Microsoft Research
of course you can open source anything
this was not the case earlier it was
kind of frowned upon it but since 2014
we've been doing a lot and we now have
some 50-plus projects on the books maybe
that sounds like a small number it's
actually quite a big number and it's
growing every month and the projects are
aimed at academia but also at developers
and they have life cycles and I'm going
to concentrate on that and show you some
graphs the challenges have been that
because you put these projects out into
repositories like get up and so on often
people can't find them how do people
find your projects the only way they
find your projects is that you give some
paper in some breakout session with 12
people in the room a Dixie that might
not be enough to get you the exposure
you need so one needs to have somewhat
of a better way
of distributing information about your
fantastic projects so what we've done is
we've got this portal on the right hand
side is a picture of what the portal
looks like and the address for it is
research microsoft com / open source and
from there you get to this portal and
the idea with the portal is that we
divide up the projects into 12
categories so that if you're an educator
and researcher out there you go first to
the category you want and then you can
find as many projects up to date as you
like so this is what it might look like
hmm it seems to be something funny in
the middle there nevermind so for
example for cloud computing it would
show you these are the ones we've
currently got and this is a new one
that's indicated as fresh so from the
point of view of industry which has a
lot of these projects as opposed to a
department which you might have fewer
advertising and getting them out there
is an issue and something we want to do
something about now we then went ahead
and interviewed over the past couple of
months all of the owners of these
projects and we asked various questions
one of the questions was why did you
open source your project so here are the
answers up at the top the graph is going
up to six or seven there the first
answer the most popular was ease of
collaboration so that meant that they
initially had collaborators often these
were interns that were going back to
their universities so it really was just
a drop box type process that's not a
very good reason for open sourcing as
such because it means you not have
taking open collaborations but it's okay
then preventing a project from dying
they were hoping
that by putting it out there other
people would just pick it up and do
something with it but this is really
just a hope in many cases increased
trustworthiness that's very important if
you put it out there you think that
other people will actually believe in
the project be able to read it and so on
and then get contributions involve the
community serve the community these are
nice nice words and people believe in
them but they're not highly practical
reasons and lastly to reproduce
published results that's quite a
practical reason wasn't em there were
only a couple of ones however they were
unforeseen benefits that people remarked
when we interviewed them that they
discovered after they had open sourced
their projects and these were that they
got improved portability from
contributors there were a couple of
cases with contributors to the projects
that said you know love your project
doesn't run on my platform and then
actually went in there and did the under
the port don't Marvis I mean that was
absolutely such a great thing that
happened people add a documentation if
they didn't understand things they
worked out and then put the
documentation back and gut github of
course the usability if people didn't
understand things that pointed it out
those things get fixed and adoption
which is one of the main avenues of
having your project out there in the
first place so so these are all benefits
that people realized afterwards rather
than motivations now some graphs these
are on the up axis on the y-axis we've
got the number of contributors going
small medium large
numbers are not really important here
because what we're trying to indicate is
that over a period of years were years
is five projects start out they become
evolving they become quite stable and
then they start winding down and they
become inactive so we discovered that
projects are by no means static what I
saw of the projects last year is not
what the projects look like this year
reasons are that people move on their
change into some other job that they're
doing the project is no longer
interesting or the project becomes very
exciting and people are just using it
and so more people have piled onto the
project so so what you've got here is
this kind of graph of our project that
we were interviewing however what's
interesting is that even though it is
industry many of the projects are still
very small with respect to contributors
outside contributors and small means
less than five to three right so it's
only a couple at the top that have
really made it into the big time now
users is very similar but a little bit
more up in that bell curve so same x
axis there and the users projects have
got more users but not as many
contributors so what you can see here is
that they start off with many users and
then the users sort of drop off and the
projects are then who'd have deemed to
be an active and I think that's a
message we've got to take away
is that it's not a failure of a project
if it starts winding down it's just
reached the end of its life that's how
projects are some graphs two more graphs
and then i'll be over these are actual
projects so audience which you'll be
able to look at in the show k in the
open source life this afternoon is one
of the active projects at the moment and
you can see in green are the Microsoft
contributors and in blue the
non-microsoft contributors and you can
see it's it's sort of from June last
year like the second half of last year
and first half of this year you know
they've been tapping out together same
numbers pretty good stable community CN
TK is a brand new project and it's
trying to build up its external
contributors it's got lots of internal
contributors still trying to build up
its internal contributors my ms AGL is
winding down so in a sense one could
imagine and it's probably true that the
community is taking this project over
now because they still are external
contributors but the internal
contributors are winding down right I
just want to advertise something right
in order to promote these open source
things we had this lovely challenge and
we had many students all around the
world piling on working on these
projects and four of them are here today
so I think we let have them stand up
come on our conver inside Anita
and they they want prizes for their work
on these projects and again once again
to demo their projects this afternoon
and what they did thank you so if any
questions about the figures or the
graphs I can talk to them scalping oh oh
yes oh where is this where is this
important when a when new projects in
Microsoft want to go open source they
generally ask around sometimes they ask
their colleagues but we now have
officers that they can ask you say you
know what should we know about open
source tell us what we should know warn
us about what the future is about so
these graphs can help indicate to people
you know there is a there is a life
Scott start there is a life cycle don't
expect that your project will always be
big don't anticipate you'll get a great
big project but you might so it's having
this model we're also working on a tool
whereby we can pull from github directly
these figures so instead of actually
getting the manually so that once the
project is is launched we can track
what's going on and these figures can be
given to the person for that purpose so
it's an interesting question is the tool
and and the model for management who is
it for the project owner and eventually
we decided for both because both are
equally and legitimately interest
did in what's going on in in the open
source arena thanks Jeff so hey I'm Jeff
Macaffer and this is ryan far we're
going to talk to you a bit about github
insights and the work we've been doing
we both work in the open source programs
office here at Microsoft and for
Microsoft folks in the room who knew
that there was an open source programs
office come on okay good so we're a body
that started about a year ago to help
drive and promote open source engagement
within the company so we got a big
company lots of software developers
60,000 of us or so and we all should be
doing open source so as you can imagine
that presents a bit of a problem when
you sort of Unleashed 60,000 eager devs
onto the open source community they
don't necessarily know how to behave
they can overwhelm people they cannot
fail the ticket they can not take
advantage of things or do it wrong so
our goal is to try to help people do it
right and one way to deal with that is
to get data to actually understand
what's going on in open source what are
we doing what are other people doing and
do this answer to the earlier question
was a perfect segue because the kind of
thing that we wouldn't be great when you
want to go and use some open source
project to be able to tell is it healthy
what life cycle stages it in are there
more like who are the contributors is
that my competitor is that I've diverse
is it all just a single company so you
know who knows consumer reports right
consumer reports you want to buy a truck
okay this is it so this is you know I
want to buy a car or a truck i go to
consumer reports and I get all this
detail about you know what other people
have experienced with it is it new does
it have bugs all that sort of stuff and
it inspires confidence in your choice of
choosing this truck or that truck or
this car or whatever so imagine that we
had this kind of dashboard for open
source projects both our own that's that
you know you think Ford cares about what
you know consumer report says probably
they go and they say hey look at this
why is
you know durability way down here at
pour in in 2016 we've got to do some
work to make that better so we care
about the the sort of quality of our
open source project engagement as the
ones that we produce but we also care
when we're going to go and say hey
windows is going to take a dependency on
this open source project we care what
that the nature of that project is so
that's one small aspect of the kind of
thing that we're trying to tackle so you
know just some examples here of
different health metrics and that this
talk is not about health metrics it's
I'm just giving sore laying the
groundwork you know how open is a
project who where the committers coming
from how many comments are there all
that sort of thing and one of the
example mechanisms you can use is
actually let me see if I can do this hey
it's going to work awesome so this is G
H torrent mode that's my that's not yet
short that's my shopping so who H start
users okay so who's actually using GH
torrent ok cool so for those of you who
don't know what GH torrent is it's a
project run by giorgio sucios at he
moved universities he's in the
netherlands and it's basically pulling
all of the data out of github all the
activity that happens on github you do a
pull request you do a file an issue you
do a push or emerge all of those things
trigger events and Ryan will tell you
about that in a minute but all of that
data is being pulled into gh torrent and
now you have basically a complete
history of all the projects for all of
github since 2012 right and that's
that's a super rich data source for
looking at behavior of communities
behavior of code nature of code etc so
one of the things that he put up you can
see the URL here is this is actually
live gh torg and you can go in here and
type in you know your favorite project
I'm iLike typescript so use typescript
and it's not just because I work at
Microsoft so this is a an analysis of
various aspects of typescript the
typescript community
so for example backlog should pull
request backlog right so somebody's done
a pull request how long is it until it
gets handled who's doing it that's kind
of what's in this report so you can see
here that the number of new and closed
is the sort of I don't I guess it looks
pink for you Green is new and left open
so those are ones that are just came in
and we haven't processed in that new and
closed is great because they are new by
some definition of time and they've
already been closed so that's really
awesome and the blue is less good
because those are so I blew it sold and
closed we're missing old and still open
but anyway pull request life lines these
are the the ten percent longest open
pull requests right and so you can look
at projects for these the ten percent
longest one then the cutoff point is 25
days so anything older than 25 days is
fits into this ten percent and you can
start seeing like well some of them have
been open a really really long time you
can imagine this being a live tool where
you could click on that say what the
heck why is that one open for four years
like what's going on with that and click
into it this one's a static static view
where commits coming from so community
versus the project oh and this one is
actually sorry is it coming in through a
pull request or a direct commit into the
inch of the repo a direct push look at
where commits are coming from right so
as a percentage coming from the
community versus versus from the actual
committers themselves again comments are
they coming from the community or the
project itself and then forking so this
is kind of interesting here you can see
that this who knows what happened on
this day what happens in about March
April every year in a Microsoft context
build the build conference right so
BUILD conference happened somebody stood
up on a stage and talked about
typescript and everybody in the audience
went and fork dick thinking I'm going to
go and do some cool things
and we can see you know whether or not
that actually happened c'est la vie that
was for the material crowd so anyway
back to the slides and so that's the
next slides are just those in
screenshots in case the internet wasn't
working you can do things now it's
interesting you start crossing this with
different data sets so geolocation and
github you're able to say where you live
to some degree of accuracy and so you
can start seeing that hey you know what
where it's cold people do more work
where it's warm they don't so that's
interesting they also cross that other
people have crossed that with all sorts
of data that I won't mention but the
other thing we're looking at doing I was
mentioning earlier to some people at the
table was crossing this with like Travis
build output right so you can start
seeing things like Bob does is really
quick to answer pull request a poll
requests put them in and they get built
and they take it all the way through
build and see that the builds usually
pass and they they don't have any test
failures Fred on the other hand is a
little sketchy and he takes a long time
to do stuff and he typically ends up
with build errors and test failures
right so you can start understanding the
nature community by harvesting all this
data together oh look at that office is
going to update I think I'll postpone
okay so these are the kinds of insights
that I was talking about Judas point
about scale like when we start scaling
up Microsoft to use open source we
really have to understand all these
different aspects and how important it
is from a sort of industrial point of
view it's not just about project hell so
things like product adoption right we
can go and look at all the github repos
and understand our people using vs code
who uses vs code so you know if I knew
your projects I wouldn't have had to ask
you I could have just gone and looked at
the gh torrent data and seen that you
have a dot vs code folder in your repo
right same thing with visual studio or
different languages api's are using the
azure
kays what api's are using from those
SDKs are using them right are you using
ones we didn't know about if i want to
change one can i go and change it and
not break people that sort of thing
those are all really cool and
interesting from a company point of view
from a sort of industrial point of view
research I mean I'm speaking to the
choir here lots and lots of different
things you can do with this data from
like a software engineering point of
view branching and pull requests
behavior code flow that kind of stuff
you know we've seen collaboration thing
people looking at collaboration
characteristics and that sort of stuff
yeah when you start mixing it with
different kinds of data like I showed
with the Geo stuff you can also look at
we did recently some mixing with climate
data as you saw there but you can also
start bringing things like stackoverflow
questions build results like I mentioned
earlier customer satisfaction for
whatever metric that is send them an
analysis over slack or Twitter or
whatever get you a more holistic view of
what's going on in a set of projects and
then finally operational insights and
this is Ryan's domain all right thank
you ok here yeah so we can also do a lot
of operational insights so we can look
at repository management user management
we can look at who assigned clas and
stuff like that but what's more
important for the stuff that I'm doing
this summer is the fact that you can do
more than just analytics with it you can
actually use it to in my case make sure
that everybody is following open-source
policies so I've kind of setup
Microsoft's github torrent which tracks
the public and private Microsoft data
and with it I've been creating bots
which we call cops that really just do
exactly that they make sure that
everybody is falling Microsoft's
open-source policies if you don't have a
license in your repository you'll
probably get an email from one of my
boat's soon in an automatic pull request
stuff like that
but how do we actually get this data
well as Jeff mentioned before oh well
actually let's look at the numbers first
so there are about 15 million users 38
million repository something like half
of which are private and about a million
events per day does Jeff mentioned
before we use gh torrent and as you can
guess Microsoft github torrent is based
on GH tour and it's just like slightly
tweaked by adding web hooks and stuff
like that so GH torrent just gathers all
of the public data and archives it it
tries to completely capture all of the
entities and how they're related and
then it enables people to do a lot of
really interesting analytics but also
you know create BOTS as I mentioned
before so how does it work well it uses
primarily the events API you have to
vent API in Microsoft github torrent we
also use web hooks to get a live stream
of data and for each event which I'll
just show you the event stream right now
if it'll work well control quick yeah we
got all right there we go yeah so if we
go to API dagaha calm / events we can
see that there's just a whole bunch of
JSON here it looks maybe even a little
bit meaningless but we can see there's a
type it's a pull request review comment
okay so let's look at the actor let's go
to their URL okay so what other repos
are they working on nothing apparently
let's look at what they have starred
nothing all right what's usually more
interesting than this was a rent this is
live data right so yeah at the time we
got that we got whatever data you get
yeah but the interesting point there is
that the you get the pull that you you
basically get this graph of data that
you get to pull on right you get these
events that you can see everything
that's going on and yeah yeah and
exactly a so what I was just doing is
almost exactly what gh torrent does it
just grabs something from the event
stream and then recursively walks the
JSON it just looks at all of the other
links and then periodically behind the
scenes it will go back
and and use the events API to make sure
that all of the data is up to date in
case there are any events that we can't
get through the event stream something
like that so here's an example just as I
showed you before but the internet works
so we're good so this tries to collect a
ton of entities really everything that
it possibly can org members pull
requests commits events followers users
Watchers so on and so forth just
everything you could possibly want how
it works is that on the right side here
you can see the event retrieval it's
just it's just a script that really uses
the events API to periodically pull from
the event stream on github and then it
will add that to a database and it will
split it up and add it to RabbitMQ event
queues and on the other side of that
there are these data retrieval processes
running that look at these events and
those are what go down the rabbit hole
and recursively walk that JSON they pull
everything they can off of github using
the github API again and then they add
it to a different database this town
MongoDB so gh torrent in its vanilla
version has data all the way back to
februari of 2012 has something like five
billion event resin my sequel and 10
terabytes of MongoDB data growing by
about 10 gigs per day so we have a ton
of data and i'll just leave to jeff to
talk about how you can use that data
sure so one of our goals in addition to
getting all these insights for ourselves
is to enable you and everybody else to
gain the insights you want to have so
there are multiple ways that you can
actually get access to this data one is
hosted i showed you already we went to
gh torrent org you can go there and you
can run some queries on MongoDB and my
sequel posted on the machines in
wherever georgios has them actually
they're probably running in our
subscription of azure data I'm sorry as
your subscription that's hosting gh
torrent but you can go there that's
great for poking around and
understanding what's going on they tend
to be their rate limited right you only
get so much compute and it's basically I
think that queries are a hundred
cans or something like that they're
limited 202nd it says it on screen so
that's good you can go poke around and
see what the date is like but you want
to do something substantial right you're
doing your research or whatever and you
want to do you know 24 by 7 queries over
all the data so you can actually go and
download the data right good the gh
torrent has a place where you can go and
grab the dumps of the databases so you
can grab that dump reconstitute it on
your machines and then do you know party
on and do what you want how many people
have grabbed those dumps anybody it was
it fun it you know it's a little
challenging it's pretty large you got to
stand up your machine then you got the
challenge of keeping it up-to-date there
are daily dumps and that sort of thing
but it's it's a bit of a you know it's a
bit of an overhead so oh actually oh yes
right so instead of doing that you can
install and and install gh torrent on
your machine it's open source software
it's on github and this is what we've
done for our private repos so Ryan
mentioned ms ght or Microsoft gh torrent
that's an instance that we run to gather
all of our data from our public repos
and our private repos because gh torrent
has only public data so you can go and
stand up all this to yourself and get it
harvesting a set of repose that you have
access to whether they're public or
private and that really that's really
cool that works really well you've got
to get a set of API keys so you don't
get rate limited by by github and you
know it's it's a fair bit more overhead
but it's it's actually really cool if
you're wanting to monitor private repos
especially what we've been doing is
trying to take all that data and put it
make it available to you easily so we've
got the sinkhole as your data lake which
is a new service being offered by the
azure team that basically has storage
and compute okay so you can it's a big
data solution so we can dump terabytes
and petabytes of data into storage and
then you can spin up compute clusters or
analysis clusters to go and work on it
and so our model here is where we're
managing the storage will keep that data
up-to-date in a shared storage place and
then you can come up with a compute
cluster and say
hey I'd like to go and do these queries
on that data and for us the work and
maintaining the data anyway so we're
just making available to you and for you
you can query as much as you want right
now it's you sequel is the query
language it's a data lake new data lake
query language but we're also Hadoop and
spark should should we haven't actually
done it but the theory is that it works
so but you know if it doesn't work we're
going to work we're going to make make
that happen so the idea then is you know
you just contact us we hook you up with
the data and then you set up your
computer cluster right now it's a copy
the sharing structure in data lake isn't
working one hundred percent to what we
need so you end up getting a copy of the
data and there's simple scripts to do it
you let it run for a couple hours and
you end up with your own copy of the
data and then you can compute on that in
the future you'll just hook your compute
to our data and share it and that is it
so if if you want to know about more
about the gh insights work it's a github
repo with some instructions and and that
sort of thing any any questions yeah
yeah the instructions are actually in
there in the repo but feel free to
contact me yeah okay thanks very much oh
I think he actually surgeon absolutely
so there are other solutions a github
archive anybody know about github
archive as well so it's something that
was run by Google and Google just came
out with a new new mechanism they put
all their data into bigquery and a big
table and you and that sort of thing so
we worked with the github guys and we've
had some various discussions about how
to make this easier and better and how
to enable dis data to be more readily
available from github proper those sorts
of things that that's still in
discussion but we're not taking you know
at the end this is all public data so
we're not doing anything against their
terms of use or whatever and we do
obfuscate
email addresses by the way so earlier it
wasn't being done and there were a few
people who got you know by the way
researchers one of the things that we
get complaints about because we've
aggregated this data is researchers
taking it getting the data and sending
emails to people saying hey would you
like to take this survey i see that
you're doing you know python that's
actually not allowed by github that's
not that's against the github terms of
use and it's a something that we get a
lot of flack about in managing things
like gah torrent so don't do that please
yeah
that's a great question so yet so
basically this should be recursive my
ideal for this is that there's a
community of researchers and other
people who are developing cool queries
and if there's some cool query that
everybody wants to know the answer till
you know super popular right and imagine
these all go into github repos and you
contribute your query and I contribute
mine and so forth and people keep
running yours will just run it all the
time and have it available in the shared
data set so people don't have to that
this is the ideal right I'd be fantastic
that would be super success if we were
able to get to that point okay thank you
very much have a great day thanks
everyone I'm mayonaka pond and this is
some work that i did with some of my
students in RIT Newton steves and Craig
it started off as a class project but
they ended up being my master students
in Newton's another PhD student and we
carried on with his work afterwards and
when I got the email to talk at this
forum I was thinking why is this topic
interesting today like why is this
interesting today and not in 2006 when I
started my PhD is a there's a lot more
access to data today then ten years ago
right we have at that time I think there
was sourceforge and a few projects in
Apache but now we have github we have
the android app store which I personally
mine and I get like tens of thousands of
apps every day from google and they kind
of just turn a blind eye towards us and
not actually tell us anything but we get
that data every day right and there's so
much data that we have that when i
started my postdoc in 2011 these servers
had two terabytes of storage and nobody
was using most of it but i was finishing
it up in 2014 we had used up almost 12
terabytes in the servers right so that's
how much data is available today and as
we heard yesterday a name for yesterday
is also compute power now right there's
sure
and there's other AWS and other services
where you can go and analyze these large
sets of repositories in reasonably ok
times so we've done studies where it
took us only 24 hours to analyze about
800,000 repositories so it's not too bad
but it's still doable so I think this
these are the two factors why analyzing
these large sets of repository from
github or any other set of repositories
is becoming popular among the research
community at least I think so but the
other reason is what can we do with this
data and I think a lot of it is going to
talk a little bit more about this later
but I think they can have a data-driven
decision support for the different
stakeholders in different stakeholders
right like you can use the large set of
repositories to answer questions for
developers or maintain Azure managers
build engineers and pns like I said
blood was going to talk a little bit
more but I just wanted to give a couple
of examples to set the context by
shockey and her colleagues had this
paper in FSC 23 2013 I think on whether
you should be using static typing or
dynamic typing it was a very
controversial favorite as well and they
used 700 repositories like before that
there weren't many studies that use that
many repositories to answer these kind
of questions right it's another study
from Fang Zhang who tried to build a
universal prediction model by building a
defect prediction model not on one data
set but on 1300 repositories together so
managers can now use this model to find
out how to predict bugs for their
repository bogdan had this other paper
on whether continuous integration was
good and it was a little bit more now
we're doubling with almost 1,800
repositories that I was used and a study
that Shane and Bram and some of my
colleagues and queens we did we used
170,000 repositories to find out what
was the relationship between bill may
intense and build technologies and one
of the things that we found out in this
study was you know technologies like
make even though seem more difficult had
considerably lower maintenance effort
than easier technologies like ant or
maven and there were several reasons for
it one being that because it was easy
people were more ready to go and turn
those files whereas make was considered
difficult so people didn't want to
really go and touch those files also
Anton maven did other things as well
beyond just build support and the final
example that I wanted to give was a
study that I was personally involved
with very closely was it always bothered
me the Dijkstra study while good had no
empirical evidence like wow ur goat is
actually bad right and so we wanted to
explore this so we looked at about
11,000 see projects in github and you
wanted to see a are they actually using
gotas anymore and we found out yes
actually about a third of the projects
that we looked at had go to his and
about eleven percent of the files in
these projects actually had go tools in
there so we wanted to see why they were
using these go tues and we found out
that most of the go to use was for error
handling and clean up like memory clean
up because she didn't have those
constructs in there in the language and
so most of the use was for very simple
purposes and what Dykstra feared like
spaghetti code right was very very rare
not many uses not many people were using
it for jumping around in their code so
because of this what we found is that
there were very few go tools that were
removed and modified in a post release
failure it hardly had any bugs so go to
this can be harmful but they need not be
if you use it for certain purposes so
this is something that we were able to
mine tens of thousands of repositories
and try to understand how people are
using go tues and how people can use go
to so this was a recommendation we can
give to developers on how to use
gorgeous but in all these projects
there's a common underlying
issue and the issue is what are these
projects that we're studying on github
you know when we studied five projects
we knew exactly what these five projects
were but when it goes to hundreds or
thousands or tens of thousands we can't
actually go in and see what these
projects are about it becomes difficult
right for example in our go to study we
took a sample of the files and we would
wanted to see what these projects were
about and we found that all of these
projects almost ninety percent of these
projects almost were driver code or
kernel code or you know very low level
system code not high level applications
at all high level applications were not
using curtains so there were certain
kind of developers who knew how to use
go tools and they were using them safely
so there is a context to our study as
well now and that can often go missing
when you analyze large sets of
repositories this is the best case
scenario the worst case scenario is that
it could be a lot of nice imagine these
projects could be student projects right
and if you study these student projects
and looked at the commit history you
might think you should be committing as
a company only at eleven o'clock on a
Friday night because that's when
assignments LD r right so it could be
tutorial projects when we analyzed the
Andhra dataset we found so many hello
world applications because the tutorial
is to create a hello world application
and if you have a Google account you can
upload the app there's no reason not to
upload these apps right so it could be
personal projects it could be fork
projects so it could be projects that
not necessarily means a project that we
should be analyzing but maybe we do want
to analyze student projects for a
particular case study and in that case
we want to choose just the student
projects right so how do we know
something is an engineered software
project or not and in most cases we want
to be studying engineered software
projects so we want to remove the nice
and we want to look only at projects
that were engineered word are actually
used as a software project right so this
is what our goal was we wanted
see how can we find these engineered
software projects in github right now
the solution is and in the past studies
that I talked about the solution is to
use some metrics that are already
available in github like stargazers or
the number of watches or the number of
forks right so the facebook iOS sdk has
like five thousand stars so it's a good
proxy to say that if you have a lot of
stars then that is an engineered
software project a student project is
not going to be forked by many people a
student project is not going to be
watched by many people right so that's a
good proxy but can we do better than
this proxy is there a better way to
actually find out if something is an
engineered software project and that's
what we wanted to do we wanted to curate
github and find engineered software
projects we use the gh star and data set
and it was it's actually surprising how
big this is going on we used a dump from
late 2014 early 2015 and it had only two
million projects in it and now it's
grown by almost one factor of 10 right
but before that we need to first define
what an engineered software project is
and and this definition is incomplete
what we have is incomplete I have to say
that caveat but we've tried to make sure
that people can add to our definition
right so we define a ninja project is
engineered if it has some kind of
architecture actually components are
talking to each other and not just stand
alone the software project has some kind
of community where people are talking to
each other there's a few people working
together it has continuous integration
it has some kind of documentation it has
some kind of history that there's some
prolonged history of people committing
regularly to the project it has issues I
mean a project without issues is I guess
not a project right like nobody is
perfect in their first time so there's
going to be issues does it have a
license and does it have testing of
course this is incomplete you can always
add more for this but these are the
eight dimensions that we came up with
initially
and then we wrote you know we had a
reference implementation where we went
and collected this information from the
github projects that we had in GH direct
and then we use these metric we
calculated these metric values and then
we used a threshold which I'll explain
in a minute and added some weights to
make sure that you know there were some
factors they were more important than
the others and each repository is given
a score in the end right determine these
thresholds we wanted to find out we
wanted to use projects that we knew were
actually engineered software projects so
we went to companies we took github
projects that were released by Amazon
Apache Facebook Google and Microsoft I'm
assuming that these companies are not
releasing Thai projects on github right
so we use these projects and we measure
the same eight dimensions to see what
values these dimensions had for projects
that we knew were projects right and we
took the minimum value minimum values so
we were very safe in saying that
something is an engineered software
project so according to our metrics the
commit frequency is two commits a month
it would still be an engineered software
project and you'd be surprised by how
many projects in github don't have even
that don't have to commit someone does
not have 0 point one percent of test
cases in the source code right like very
low threshold and still a lot of
projects did not cross these thresholds
so by using these we were able to look
at the repositories and score these
repositories and as an example we have
this repository here called pre mailer
which turns CSS blocks into style
attributes and it has a lot of stars it
has about five hundred seventy-six stars
so our old metric by using stars would
have said that this is an engineered
software project and our method also
said this was an engineer software
project it had a perfect score of
hundred but there was some interesting
repositories that we found out for
example this project called retaliation
had a lot of stars at about four hundred
fifty nine stars but the whole project
was one Python file and all this did was
if someone broke the build it fires up
like
the foam rocket from a USB port and it
goes and hits them and that's all it did
so it's a cool project so a lot of
people wanted to use it but this hardly
any commits to it there's no issues in
it and it was just a tie project right
so we really can't learn much from this
as an engineered software project but
look at the other side of it is this
project called yard d receiver which is
an actual project I think because it has
a lot of commits it has a lot of
contributors it has issues is actually
communication and the purpose is to you
know execute a yard t shell but if you
look at the number of stars it has only
one style so we would not pick this
project up in our old analysis and
because of that we won't be able to
analyze projects like this will be
missing out very interesting projects
where we can't just give anecdotal
evidence and say that our approach is
great right so we want to still evaluate
it so we have to go in and collect some
ground truth data so we took a sample a
statistically valid sample of 384
projects and we manually classified them
as projects or not projects not
engineered software projects or not
engineered software projects and we
didn't use any of the dimensions we
didn't use any of the metrics that we
calculated we just used the
documentation that was there in the
project we read through the
documentation the readme files and the
purpose and all of those things to see
to classify if a project is actually an
engineered software project or not and
based on this we found out that our
approach has about 75% position so about
twenty-five percent of the times we say
something is engineered and it's not and
I think it's because of the low
thresholds that we have we classify I
mean they can be a group of four
students who are working together
diligently on a project and you could
classify that as an engineer software
project so it is possible and we also
had a recall of about sixty seven
percent which means that we were missing
some which could have been projects but
again this could have been a very good
student project that when we classified
it we could have thought this is
definitely a project when it
not have been when we compared this
against the stargazers approach we found
out that precision was 100% so every
time a project had a lot of stargazers
it was definitely a project in our
sample but recall is fine six nine
percent it's not sixty-nine percent its
point six nine percent so we are missing
out ninety nine point three percent of
interesting projects right we're looking
at a very small sample when we are
making these decisions about what
engineers should be doing a vast
majority of it we're not including so I
think that this is going to become an
issue because we are only considering
projects from Apache and Google and all
of these big companies but not the
smaller things there's there was a
another example of a ruby project which
had ten stars so much discussion and it
is a very important project but it
wouldn't get chosen right so we could
have learned something from that that we
are now missing oh so yeah that's the
results so we wanted to make sure that
other researchers have access to all of
this as well so all our analysis on the
two million repositories that we did is
available so if you go to that website
you have the paper the data that you can
download all the individual dimension
values the scores and the links to the
repositories we actually got contacted
by a researcher from NC State who wanted
to find out all projects that had test
code alone so they could avoid all the
other dimensions and only pick the
testing dimension and pick projects for
that right so and you can have your own
scoring mechanism because we've given
you the raw data and you can pick
projects are based on that we also
wanted to make sure that if you wanted
to add another dimension it was going to
be easy so we release the source code as
well and all that you have to do if you
come up with a new dimension is to just
add a script that calculates that metric
and three lines of code in our main file
and that's it you're all set to
calculate new values as well
so with that I'll stop yeah my sequel
code yeah and and if you look at it
since quite small font up there but out
of the 2.2 million projects what we
think that engineered is only about
250,000 right I mean there could be
others as all but we think only about
250 thousand of them are engineered
software projects arrest or not there
was some dimensions for which we had to
actually get the repository get the code
with gh torrent didn't have but we had
the links so we got it and then we
calculated those yeah yeah so if you
actually go to the website we have a CSV
file so you can download the whole CSV
file with the links and everything and
then you can query it yeah so this
whatever you can see here is available
as just an excel file a CSV file for you
to download
the CSV file is not big it's about ten
megabytes so it's only 2.2 million rolls
right so it's not very big it's a pretty
small data sets yes yes it doesn't solve
the problem of context so we did some
work I did some work with Tom and Chris
a few years back which we published in
FSC then where we wanted to see
diversity of projects so we still so
this is the first step right after you
get engineered software projects then
you can partition these projects into
different bins and try to do analysis on
all the bills and get some context there
you want some projects which has a lot
of commit history not a lot of commit
history thousand developers maybe ten
developer so you can still split it
based on these metrics and get a little
bit more context but you still don't
have the domain context that is still
missing
each each each is a project each is a
project not a typo this is each of it a
project or a repo yes so this is each
repo each we go not regularly because we
as regularly as we can get gh star and
data set so that was why I was asking if
we can yes yeah yeah yes yes yeah
exactly that's the goal right that's the
goal and we haven't updated it since
we've done one update so the first try
that we did it had about a million
repository is the second dump that we
had it had or two million repositories
but it's still quite oh it's just a year
and a half old but it's still old now
okay thank you
okay as I forget forgot actually one
thing infant reduction which was to
mention our organizer team so it's not
just me who organizes its actually Andy
beggar we was in the back Chris Burt
ozone feedback true that Bishop also
helpless organized Trevor Trevor oh
you're was via Trevor and Hong you sang
from MSHA he unfortunately cannot be
here today okay